all right let's go to kelly in nashville
almost 10 years ago
we found out that my mom had been having
an affair with a man in the neighborhood
and obviously things were tense for a
little bit but my parents decided to
stay together
and work things out since that time
neither of them
from my excuse me point of view um
have really made any significant changes
or efforts towards a healthier marriage
so um i guess flash forward
a couple days before christmas i got a
call from my sister
saying that my dad had found
more emails that my mom had sent to this
man
and my sister felt the pressure kind of
not to say anything to me
but really to either
well my other sibling so
but she couldn't really carry it all by
herself so she was obviously telling me
and since that time she's admitted to my
dad that she did tell me
um and so she was kind of pulled in as a
mediator
at the moment and um
i you know and so then i was the support
for
the mediator in secret what a mess
hey so real quick real quick so did your
mom kick back up this affair with this
dude or did your dad find
stuff from 10 years ago no
it's back ah okay in the way you said it
the dude in the neighborhood so the dude
in the neighborhood still
is in the neighborhood and so he's he's
back in action right
and how old are you i'm 29.
okay and how old your little sister
uh 26. okay
so we're all adults um except for except
for your parents
but go ahead well right um
well and so my my sister since admitted
to my dad that
um she told me so you know my dad
followed up with me
and um kind of got i guess my thoughts
on the
situation um i don't know if anyone
has told my brother or not um i did also
end up reaching out to my mom
to just to let her know that i still
love her
and i still support her but really my
question today i'm just trying to figure
out what is my responsibility in this
situation
to my family as a whole and then
you know what's my responsibility to my
mom my dad
my brother my sister each as individuals
that's a great question and just for the
record i hate that you got drawn into
this i hate that your
dad did that to your sister and
triangulated her in that way he should
have some friends and some confidants
and or a counselor or a place where he
can go and talk to grown-ups about these
challenges but um and i hate that for
your sister and
your poor brother how old is he
uh he's 27. yeah and leave it to the
brother just like hey everybody what
y'all doing ryan has no idea just be
bopping along right
exactly so um here's my thought
um
thought number one is secrets
destroy families period and
my guess is if there has been um 10
years absence here and there's been no
reconnection and all i would tell you as
much as you think you know and you can
see
you probably know 25 to 35
of what actually goes on behind closed
doors with your mom and dad
and so what i would challenge you with
is staying out of the
you all didn't do any work the judge the
judgment part of what went on behind
closed doors
um because that's going to make you nuts
and it's going to make your parents have
to fight their kids
and don't do that to them unfortunately
you're forced to be the adult here
if i'm you and i've got a sister and a
brother
i would call them we'd have a three-way
talk and we would talk it out and let
everybody be on the same page
because i'm not going to hold secrets
from my brother and sister because i'm
an adult
and if my dad were to call me and burden
me with that
i would let him know i'm gonna let my
brother and sister know
because i'm not your therapist and i'm
not bound by confidentiality now i'm not
gonna go tell the neighborhood right but
i am not gonna hold secrets so that
we're all together and we're all on
different pages and different stories
i think what you did for your mom is to
let her know that you love her
is noble i think that's good she's going
to need some support
i also think it's good for you to let
your dad know that you love him
what i would do is send them both a
something in writing
your mom and your dad at the same time
that says we all know
we're not going to get involved in your
marriage um
i don't and you can feel free to say
what's on your heart and your mind
but let them know we are not going to be
triangulated into this mess
they are responsible for dealing with
their marriage and um they are
responsible for dealing with their
relationship with each other
and the dude in the neighborhood and
whoever else and whatever else
but you can't solve that you can't get
in the middle of it and all you're going
to do is wage war with your
brother and sister and your family and
at this point you've got to be the grown
up in that deal
i and know i'm telling you to do
something hard which is to not get right
down in the middle of that mud because
that's tempting
isn't it yeah yeah um
are you angry with any any one of them
or both of them
um are heartbroken what are you feeling
[Applause]
my sister kept telling me she thought
that i was kind of emotionally
disconnected
from the situation because i think 10
years ago when it happened
um i kind of came to terms
well maybe i didn't maybe i just
repressed it but i felt like i've kind
of come to terms with
um maybe they'll stay together maybe
they won't
but i think um the thing that kind of
kept me going was knowing that
regardless god was still faithful in my
life
regardless of what happened so that was
kind of my anchor
um and you know my
i was real close with both of them
growing up
um i think my dad and i in the past year
or so
have kind of butt heads sometimes a
little um
so there's part of me that's angry with
him because i've seen
some of the ways that uh he's
hurt my mom and like he said
you know i've probably not seen all of
it obviously it goes both ways
um so that in some degrees has made me
angry at him
with my mom i've been angry number one
because she's so good at being sneaky
and you know i i never knew how sneaky
she was
and so just seeing that and realizing
that now
but um can i tell you something you you
maybe didn't know how sneaky she was but
i promise
the 16 year old um kelly absorbed it
you knew it and my guess is if you go
back to
12 year old kelly and 11 year old kelly
were things just rosy and wonderful at
the house
and they were growing up there you go
okay
and so you absorbed that and um
yeah man that's tough to unwind
and so when you were 19 and this came
out did it just blow your mind
oh yeah definitely how'd you find out
um so my so
the guy that she cheated with um asked
to meet my dad at a mcdonald's
in the area oh oh dude
that's a brave guy
well no sorry it was his wife um
that told my dad and so i knew
he was going and when he came back you
know obviously something was wrong
i had no idea it was so the dude in the
neighborhoods i feel like i'm like we're
middle schoolers now so the dude in the
neighborhood
the dude in the neighborhood called your
dad no the dude in the neighborhood's
wife calls your dad to meet at
a diabetes factory and they met there
and that's where they told him
yeah from my from my recollection that
that's how my time dude that is so 10
years ago because right now he would
just text
that's it so good for them i don't think
my dad probably
suspected sure he just didn't have the
proof
and this other guy's wife brought the
proof okay
so fast forward to now i i can get
distracted pretty easily with that story
because that just sounds like there's
layer after layer after layer of that
one
here's the deal you hear me say this all
the time
you're gonna have to grieve that story
and
you had a perfect family and they
weren't perfect there is no perfect
family
and your dad made some decisions your
mom made some decisions
the the neighbor the dude in the
neighborhood
his wife at the mcdonald everybody made
decisions here and
are you married now yes okay
um you're gonna have to have some honest
conversations with your husband you're
gonna have to have some honest
conversations with your brothers and
sisters
and again going back to my original
thing i would put in writing to my mom
and dad
here's we all know we are all we love
you
we are not getting in the middle of this
mess and if you all don't act like
adults
and deal with this mess in a way that is
whole for everybody then you all are
opting out of thanksgiving because we're
all getting together
and you all are opting out of christmas
get togethers because we're all getting
together
and we're gonna mourn the loss of the
family that we thought we had
but we're not gonna get sucked into this
thing and so dad you're not calling
little sister to
gossip about mom and mom you're not
calling middle brother to
talk about if your dad had only we're
not doing that we're not playing that
game
and um the reason i tell you to write a
letter
is that way they can go back to it over
and over and over again
and when people are having hard
conversations with one another
especially family members
old roles pop up old stories pop up old
defense mechanisms pop up and we start
hearing only what we want to hear
and there's something about having a
letter that you can go back to and go
back to and go back to
okay and it will probably be a heavy
thing for them to read and they'll read
it two
three four times and they may text you
and say who the crap you think you are
and um you can tell them i'm your oldest
daughter and i love you guys
and you can just sit with that but i'll
tell you um
you are going to have to kelly go
through your own grieving process here
and you may have
everybody grieves differently your
brother may break down on all like just
be comatose weeping and you may say that
really sucks i'm pissed at my mom pissed
my dad
you morons you blew up something great
and
i hope you're all happy and i'm moving
on about my life because my marriage is
good too
that may be awesome may be good or you
may find sneaky tendencies in yourself
and you may find that you slowly start
to fill
x or y or z or you may find yourself
starting to respond to problems between
you and your husband or challenges that
we all have
kind of like your dad maybe a little
loud a little aggressive a little angry
and when you have those seasons you've
got to commit now to making sure that
you don't repeat that cycle with your
husband
um and then be open to your brother and
sister man make sure that they've got a
place to call which can be you
um and make sure you love them but that
just sucks i hate that for you
and again i say this all the time
parents out there don't treat your kids
like your therapist man that's not what
they're for don't treat
it drives me crazy when people say um
you know my son he's 14 we're best
friends i'm best friends with my dad
i was think what's so weird dude have
friends your own age
if i was to go out in the neighborhood
and be like hey this is my best friend
he's 14
i'd go to jail cause that's i probably
go to jail but that's just weird
right have friends your own age and if
you've been cheating on your spouse
don't make the first call
to your 21 year old daughter talk to a
pastor talk to a friend
talk to i don't know maybe your husband
would be a good person talk to you talk
to a counselor but talk to people who
are equipped with this
don't dump that type of nonsense onto
your children man that's so much
if you have six-year-old kids don't talk
about your marriage problems or your
six-year-old kids
why because they're six and dragons are
still maybe kinda real
and so is santa and they don't even know
about dad or they don't need
don't do that to your children okay get
people who are grown ups that you can be
vulnerable with
and what i find often is that it's hard
for grown-ups to be vulnerable
you owe it to your kids to not dump this
crap onto them